[Music]
okay everyone i'm
really really excited today because i am
joined by
everybody's favorite father father
gabriel aka
seth gilliam seth how are you doing
today i'm great thanks
thanks it's nice to be with you yeah so
seth after this wild finale that just
aired it's amazing to see the
transformation of father gabriel from
being where we saw at the beginning of
his character arc and walking dead
being this chicken and now he's like
this huge leader and he's got these big
moments now he's
leading in this tower against these
whispers and zombies so
a question i had though watching gabriel
scenes in the finale is that
there's a moment where we can believe
that
he thinks he's about to die he talks to
judith
basically telling you to go tell rosita
something for him can you kind of get us
in the mindset of gabriel here
and why he might have been accepting
that he wasn't
he was going to leave rosita and her
baby behind and that he was about to die
i think seeing the sheer numbers was
a telling sign to him i think
not quite really understanding
what makes the whispers tick because
they're so
so far behind this comprehension that
that people could do what they do
and the way that they do it and seeing
the numbers that they
had against the numbers that he had
i think kind of played a little bit on
his
doubt that he would make it out at that
time but i think he also
had a great deal of faith that he would
be able
to protect them that he would
probably end up giving his life but that
it wouldn't be the fault of their
community
that's really interesting you say that
and i think that the audience can really
feel that too and i think
as a viewer you're you're watching
what's happening to gabriel and like
you're like oh my god this guy is about
to die we're about to lose him
and he survived so when you're actually
reading the script for an episode like
this are you getting paranoid like
oh my god is this is this my time to go
like do you feel that when you're always
reading a script for walking dead
i mean you have a conversation where you
know they say that there's
something that's coming up you want to
keep an eye out for
um but
you're never quite sure you know
so it does get tense
but that's that's part of the excitement
of the job i mean
you know you know that anybody's never
could be called at any time
so if it's yours you just hope that it's
going to be something that's worthy
of the character of the journey that the
character has been on
so reading up to it i was like all right
if he's going this is the way it is this
is the way it is
you know yeah absolutely and i thought
that it was an awesome scene because
gabriel got to be the one who was
rescued by a returning
popular character as well in maggie uh
so
yeah what was that like with lauren
cohen being back on set can you kind of
give us
a little idea into that that was great
that was really great and i was really
excited that i was going to be a part of
the great reveal you know in this moment
of
certain doom for father gabriel there's
the reveal of you know a
pope coming back you know and maggie's
return
and i was really excited that i was
going to be a part of that and i i
i haven't actually uh seen the episode
yet
so i know the way that we shot it my
response and reaction to her
was one that i thought was would be
genuine for uh
for gabriel at the time and kind of you
know in a way it was
me wanting to throw back you know the
welcome open arms
you know yeah absolutely how did it look
by the way did you see the episode
oh yeah and it looked amazing it was it
just hit so emotionally because i'm sure
too like you're saying doing truth to
gabriel's character but it also probably
came easy for you right because like
it is also a reunion of two actors right
that like
yeah she's back you know yeah and i
think your story's been so interesting
this season it's probably actually my
favorite
gabriel story arc of any season and i
thought one of the big moments for me
was when gabriel earlier in the season
killed dante so can you kind of
clear up for us why he decided not to
give dante
any mercy here i think at that point
he decided that the whispers as a
collective with something beyond
his understanding and beyond redemption
and and they deserved what they were
putting out in the world
you know yeah i think if dante hadn't
hadn't interwoven himself in the fabric
of the community so
deeply then gabriel might have given it
more thought but that he could
so easily and still do what he did
i think was a little bit beyond his his
understanding of people
and he's like yeah you uh you're just
evil and
you gotta go yeah so
that that's interesting and it's
interesting because to me gabriel's such
a
complicated character especially with
his morals and his faith and
at this point with the character gabriel
where would you
say his core is moral wise like what
is his belief at the end of the day as
just a person i think he stands on the
side of people
are ultimately given the opportunity
people will do what is the right thing
however people are very complicated
and people are very dangerous or can be
i think where we
met him years ago on the top of that
rock i don't think he was aware of that
i think he was just terrified of people
and i don't think that he was aware that
there was something that could be
redeemed
in people because i don't think he was
felt he was worthy of redemption himself
so i think i think he's kind of found
a bit of peace with himself throughout
this journey
and it's allowed him to be more
accepting
more accessible to what makes people
tick
and i think his dealings with negan have
greatly informed that you know his
weekly meetings or whatever
or bi-weekly meetings with negan where
they would sit and talk and he would
basically get to know the mind of a
psychopath right someone who was
extremely charming
and she seemed very capable
of rational clear thought and action
who would choose to brutally murder
people brutally kill people to make a
point
to enslave mentally other people you
know and try to get
to the other side of what that's all
about
i think helped to fortify gabriel's
resolve in some sense and kind of
strengthen him
i i think he felt that he was able to
reach negan in a way
that he wouldn't have been capable of
years earlier that's really
a awesome connection actually to negan
it shows how much they kind of impact
each other's characters and i'm curious
with you too you you mentioned like
going back to scenes of gabriel way back
and how long you've been on the show as
an actor
is it challenging to keep up with such a
long story arc
and what keeps it interesting for you at
this point like what are the kind of the
pros and cons to it i think what keeps
it interesting for me
is that it remains challenging because
there are lots of twists and turns of
this character that we've
that i've been given to play with you
know over the course of these last seven
years
and each one has been telling well how
do i make that connect to what i just
played
how do i make that text what i just
played oh
okay well that's another shade of
the color of the palette of this
character
okay so that's another shade and that's
another shade that's another color and
that's another color
and that's what keeps it interesting the
writers have been fantastic
in my opinion with uh with crafting this
character in a way
that he can do extreme things but you
can see where they come from
so they're believable it's just
admirable how you've gone this
long and done such an amazing job
portraying this character that's so
beloved from the comics as well
and oh thank you coming to that
how do you feel now about it being
officially announced that this is the
last season coming up in season 11.
is it emotional for you can you just
give us your reaction to it and how
you're
approaching going into it well i was
kind of
i guess a bit shocked i had you know
the original show could go on like you
know gun smoke
you know give us a good 20 20 some odd
years of it
but all all good things i guess must
come to an end though it's
apparently it's not the complete end
they've got anthologies and
different you know all kinds of branches
coming off of the same
tree so uh it doesn't really feel
as final as i guess other
jobs would you know yeah
because i know that i can still tune in
and be and be taken away
on a different path of the same show and
the same
people care about and uh and watch them
go off and do
cool things so you know it's not like uh
oh i won't be seeing them against them
no i just go out on tv and i'll see if
it's the latest devices
you know yeah yeah
and i'll tell you as a viewer it's gonna
be a bittersweet ending to see it i'm
just so happy that your character
is gonna be in the final season that was
the breath of our share i really thought
we were gonna lose you there for a
second
yeah everyone please make sure if you
haven't for some reason watch the finale
yet it's on amc premiere also on amc on
demand and we'll be replaying a lot on
amc itself
you can also catch up with the walking
dead on netflix re-watch
all the great episodes of father gabriel
and if you love seth gilliam you can
also check him out in
oz and the wire he's a knack for being
in amazing shows it's only because he
contributes so much as well so
thank you so much seth for joining me
and i hope to talk to you again for
season 11.
okay thanks a lot man nice to meet you
nice to meet you have a good one